Memorizing versus learning.
Very often people say to me, you
know, I can't learn languages
because I have a poor memory.
And many people think that language
learning is a matter of memorizing things.
Uh, it's not uncommon to see
people studying lists of words.
Um, bookstores have, you know,
the thousand words or the 5,000
words, you know, for TOEFL.
Uh, and people study these and they
deliberately try to memorize them.
Uh, some people have, um, memorization
techniques, uh, some of these
memorization techniques called mnemonics
a date back to the ancient Romans.
Um, I don't use any of these.
I don't even use space
repetition actually.
Uh, I make no deliberate
attempt to memorize anything.
To me, learning is more what the
great Brazilian educator Rubem Alves
described as a vagabond experience.
What I've sometimes called
grazing, uh, what Robert Bjork
referred to as interleaving.
It's kind of exploring different
things, seeing something over here,
which we then forget and see again
somewhere else, and slowly we learn.
Uh, it is important to
have a positive attitude.
It is important to spend the
time, but it's also important to
be aware of how the brain works.
Again, I often quote Manfred
Spitzer, he says, the brain
cannot do otherwise than learn.
The brain learns slowly and the brain
requires repetition and novelty.
So with the repetition, it's not a
matter of trying to repeat something to
yourself over and over again, or reading
the same list over and over again, or
testing yourself with flashcards, it's
more a matter of noticing things that
cause certain neurons to fire together.
So if I read a text in Persian and then
I listen to the same text, the audio of
it, I will remember having read some of
those words, especially if I'm all already
somewhat familiar with those words.
And then I hear them and then I notice
them and, and then I might read it again.
And all of this is causing these
neurons, at least is the way I see it,
to fire together and gradually those
connections are getting stronger.
And because the brain requires both
repetition and novelty, if you can
do this, you know, repeating in
contexts that are of interest to
you, that contain new information...
like I listened to the news in Persian,
uh, that's gonna help you remember it.
Uh, or conversely, because the
repetition is so important.
Uh, you know, in fact, I see this
whole repetition thing as a matter
of, of hooks, of connections.
I think there's a, an expression in
this Sufi Islamic, uh, philosophy that
says you can only learn things that you
already know, so you have to have seen
it once, and then you discover it again,
or you hear it, and then you read it.
And all of this is helping to
reinforce these neural connections.
To enable you to learn words, not
through memorization, but through this
exploring vagabond type of learning.
The same is true if with grammar.
If you have no experience with the
language and you read a grammar
explanation, it makes no impact on you.
If you have had a lot of exposure to the
language and then you read an explanation
of a structure, it's possible that that
might help you notice that structure.
Once you've noticed that structure
in different situations, read it and
heard it, and been aware of it and and
so forth, then because you now sort of
kind of know it, you can now learn it.
And that sort of transformation
from something that you have
subconsciously sort of acquired to
where it becomes something that you
can consciously use, that is a gradual
process and not one that, in my
opinion, we can deliberately control.
So I think every effort to deliberately
memorize something or deliberately
learn something is not very efficient.
I don't say that it's useless because it
is a form of exposure, but uh, there's all
kinds of research that shows that if we
read the same material over and over again
with the intention of sort of memorizing
it, we are in fact learning less and less,
and we are better off to provide that
novelty, that change to the brain so that
the brain can go off and look at something
else and then come back and rediscover,
relearn something that's gonna be a
more efficient way of acquiring words.
And as I've said many times,
language learning is largely
a process of acquiring words.
So the, the language learning um,
the model that I like is one where
I'm learning in a vagabond way
rather than deliberately memorizing.
And I think part of doing that, and part
of, uh, believing in that is, is, is to
accept the fact that that is how we learn.
Don't try to short circuit, speed it
up, force yourself, shove it, shove it
down your throat, it isn't gonna work.
Believe that your brain is always
learning, and if you give it enough
exposure in different situations,
uh, some easy content, some difficult
content, sometimes listening to the
words, sometimes reading the words, maybe
doing the odd, you know, matching pairs,
which is my favorite form of, of, you
know, flashcard review, but other people
have other forms of flashcard review.
It's all part of the exposure
to the language and the greater
the variety of the exposure.
The greater the different levels
of difficulty, the more we are
learning and the less we are
deliberately trying to memorize.
I think in the end we enjoy the
process more and we're more successful.
So there's my take on
memorization versus learning.
Look forward to your comments.